This is Dr. Leder, and
I'm here to present
aphasias and common
****** syndromes.
The session objectives
today include
identifying different
types of aphasias,
localizing the different
types of strokes and
****** syndromes with
the arteries that
supply them, understanding
the differences
between an arterial
and a venous ******,
recognizing risk
factors for venous
infarcts and recognizing
the infarcts themselves
and being able
to recognize the
different types of
intracranial hemorrhages.
So in terms of
epidemiology of ******,
it is the second
leading cause of
both death and
disability worldwide.
87% of strokes are
ischemic in nature. so
when we talk about
strokes the risk factors
are broken into both
modifiable and non
-modifiable modifiable
means something that
can be changed whereas
non-modifiable is
a risk factor that
you can't change so
regular use of cigarettes
and cannabis high
blood pressure elevated
lipids diabetes,
kidney disease,
untreated sleep
apnea, heavy alcohol
use, a poor diet, and
atrial fibrillation
are all risk
factors that are
modifiable. Non
-modifiable risk factors
include male ***,
advancing age,
genetic susceptibility,
and race. It
is known that
African Americans are
at higher risk of
having strokes.
A Mediterranean diet
is associated with
a lower risk of
****** and includes
high intake of olive
oil, fruits and
vegetables, nuts and
whole grains, and
a moderate intake
of fish and poultry.
So in the first case,
there's a 72-year
-old man who has a
history of elevated
blood pressure,
cholesterol, and diabetes.
He presents with
right-sided weakness,
speech difficulty.
He's able to
follow commands,
understands, and reads,
but has difficulty
producing speech and
is unable to both
repeat or to write.
So before we get to
his case, which side
of the brain is language
function generally
localized? And why do
neurologists always
ask if a patient is
right or left-handed?
So most patients over
90% of patients who
are right-handed
have their language
function on the left
side of their brain, and
left-handed people
have more like 70%
localized to the left
side of their brain.
Some people who
are left-handed may
have their language
function on both left
or right. It's a
little bit lower.
And so after someone's
had either a ******
or some other
insult to the brain,
there is the question
of hand dominance.
So there are different
types of aphasia,
but aphasia is based
on spontaneous speech,
comprehension, naming,
repetition, writing,
and reading. When you
see these aphasias,
they're often not
seen in isolation.
And so the
different types of
aphasia include
Broca's aphasia,
which is an
expressive aphasia,
Wernicke's aphasia,
which is receptive.
There's transcortical
motor and
transcortical sensory
aphasia, global
aphasia, and
conduction aphasia.
So getting back to our
72-year-old man, he
had an expressive
or Broca's aphasia,
which commonly occurs
as a result of a very
large left middle
cerebral artery infarct,
will involve the
frontal lobe and
extend into the
superior temporal lobe.
There, it is
characterized by short,
simple sentences
or one to two word
utterances, and it's
non-fluent. These
patients understand
what's going on and
generally appear to
be very frustrated.
A receptive or Wernicke's
aphasia stems from
a large middle
cerebral artery infarct
but the lesions to
the left posterior
perisylvian cortex.
There's poor
speech comprehension
with word deafness
and the language
is empty with a lack
of meaningful content.
transcortical motor
aphasia is associated
with a ****** to the
left hemisphere but
it spares the
perisylvian cortex and is
usually associated with
a frontal lobe lesion
there is non-fluent
or hesitant speech
the repetition is
intact there is good
comprehension and an
anterior cerebral artery
territory lesion is
generally the cause.
Transcortical
sensory aphasia is an
analog of Wernicke's
receptive aphasia
where there's poor
comprehension, intact
repetition to the
point that there
may even be some
echolalia. Again,
there's sparing of the
perisylvian cortex,
and reading and
writing is impaired.
With global aphasia,
there's expressive
and receptive
aphasia both.
Speech is non-fluent
or mute. Comprehension
is poor. Naming,
repetition,
reading, and writing
are all affected, and
there is a left MCA
lesion with inferior
frontal and superior
temporal gyrus lesion.
Conductive aphasia
occurs from a ******
to the posterior,
superior temporal
gyrus, and supermarginal
gyrus region. There
is nearly normal
spontaneous speech
but striking difficulty
with repetition.
Auditory comprehension
is preserved.
So the second case
is a 62-year-old man
who states that he's
unable to see out
of his left eye. How
do you know if this
is the left eye
or the left visual
field? So the first
thing that's done is
you have the patient
cover one eye, so
you can determine if
it's just one whole
visual field or if
it's the actual eye.
So with a posterior
cerebral artery
infarct, these
arteries are the major
terminal branches of
the basilar artery.
They supply branches
to the midbrain,
thalamus, occipital
lobes and medial and
inferior temporal
lobes. A unilateral
infarction of the
occipital lobe can cause
contralateral
homonymous hemianopsia.
Neglect is an
inability to process
information on one side
of the body. It's more
severe after a right
-sided cerebral lesion
and can occur after
the presence of a
right posterior
parietal ******. The
patient may treat a
body part is foreign. As
you can see in this
picture, this patient
is not aware of the
left side of their
body, and that's
why the food is
left there, as
they're just not aware
of it or they're
neglecting it.
Amorosis fujax
is a transient
monocular binocular
vision loss.
It is a vascular cause
for the vision loss
and patients often
describe that either
a shade is being
pulled down or there's
constriction of the
visual field. This
lesion can distinguish
an internal carotid
artery versus an
MCA infarction. The
central retinal artery
occlusion is likely
the cause of this
condition and it's a
branch from the
carotid. Therefore, when
this occurs, it's more
likely that this is
an ICA lesion rather
than an MCA lesion.
Alexia without agraphia
is a syndrome that
occurs generally
after a left posterior
cerebral artery
infarction. It results in
a left occipital
region with splenium of
the corpus callosum.
There is associated
pure word blindness,
the inability to read,
but they do retain
the ability to write.
Gerstmann syndrome
may be from a PCA
territory infarction
that affects the angular
gyrus or from MCI
involving angular gyrus.
The symptoms of a
Gerstmann include
the presence of
acalculia, which
means that they
can't do simple math.
Agraphia, they can't
write. Finger agnosia
means that they're unable
to distinguish which
finger is the thumb,
which is the pinky.
They also can't
determine left from
right. There's a
disorientation.
These are rare strokes,
but may be asked
on different type
of board exams.
An anterior cerebral
artery infarction
is uncommon in
isolation, usually
less than 3%. This
type of a ******
can occur due to
two main types of
interruption to the
brain's blood flow.
There could be a
blockage or a clot.
Hemorrhagic
****** could also
occur due to an
aneurysm rupture.
When there's an
anterior cerebral artery
infarction, it is associated
with contralateral
lower extremity
weakness more than arm
weakness. And the
patients exhibit ebulia,
akinetic mutism, and
they have impaired
memory and emotional
disturbances as well.
With an internal
carotid artery
******, both ACA
and MCA branches
are affected because
they come off
of the internal
carotid artery.
There's often an
atherosclerotic plaque
or critical stenosis
at the cervical
bifurcation, and it's
associated with contralateral
hemiparesis and
hemisensory loss,
with the face more
affected than the arm
or the leg, and motor
is more affected than
sensory. There could
also be transient
central retinal artery
occlusion, and if
that occurs, this is
a better prognosis
than if there's a full
hemispheric ******.
For a middle cerebral
artery ******, this
is the largest branch
of the ICA and the most
common site of an
ischemic ******. It
occurs with contralateral
weakness to the face
more than the arm and
more than the leg.
it's described as
looking at your
****** as there's
gaze deviation
toward the side
of the lesion
these are a list of
the different brainstem
syndromes that can
occur and you're not
responsible for them
only the ones that i'll
go into more detail
you should be familiar
with but these are all
different possibilities
of brainstem strokes
that can occur.
The locked-in syndrome
is probably the most
severe neurologic
condition with near-total
body paralysis but
preserved consciousness.
There's damage to the
brainstem. The ventral
pons is the most vulnerable
area. the patient
remains alert with
quadriplegia and
anarthria. So they are
unable to speak, they're
unable to move, and the
way that they're able
to communicate is only
through vertical eye
movements. And this
book, The Diving Bell
and the Butterfly,
describes what it feels like
to be trapped in this
locked-in syndrome.
And patients are able to
communicate simply
by blinking or
moving their
eyes up and down.
The lateral medullary
syndrome is one
that's not very
common, but often asked
on many board exams.
This is also known
as the Wallenberg
syndrome. It is associated
with vertigo,
nausea, vomiting, and
nystagmus, numbness
to the ipsilateral
face and contralateral
body, ipsilateral
ataxia, ipsilateral
paralysis of larynx,
pharynx, and loss
of the gag reflex.
The man-in-a-barrel
syndrome is associated
with anoxia to the
cerebral border zones due
to systemic hypoperfusion.
There's associated
bilateral arm weakness
that spares the
lower extremities and
damage to cortex that
carries over to
the arms. So there
is significant
arm weakness as if
a patient is
trapped in a barrel.
There are five different
types of lacuna
infarcts. There's the
pure motor that generally
localizes to the
posterior limb of
internal capsule, a pure
sensory lacuna infarct,
which likely localizes
to the ventral
posterior lateral
nuclear thalamus, a mixed
sensory motor, which
is thalamocapsular.
Dysarthria clumsy
hand syndrome is the
genu of the internal
capsule or the basis
pontus, and then
attacks a chemiparesis,
which is basis pontus
and internal capsule.
Case three is a 57
-year-old man who
presents with a two
-minute episode of left
-handed weakness. It
was unusable during
the episode. Walking
and talking, though,
was normal throughout
this episodes.
When he arrives
at the emergency
department, he's
back to normal
and the CT of his
head was normal.
This is a TIA or a
transient ischemic
attack, which is a
temporary blockage of
blood flow to the
brain. The clot usually
dissolves on its own
or gets dislodged.
Symptoms usually
last less than five
minutes, but can last
up to 24 hours. A TIA
can help prevent a
****** as it is a
warning of a bigger
****** that may occur.
The clinical
challenge of a TIA is
the fact that it
could look like many
things, such as a
migraine, epilepsy,
multiple sclerosis,
peripheral nerve
entrapment, or a brain
hemorrhage, including
a subdural. The motor
and speech symptoms
have a higher likelihood
of brain ischemia
as the cause of the
symptoms, and about 20
% of patients presenting
with these TIAs will
have a ****** within
the next 90 days, The
highest risk, though,
is within the next 24
hours of the event.
So strokes can be
treated in the short
term with IV
thrombolysis, such as TPA,
mechanical
thrombectomy, where they
actually go in and
can retrieve the clot.
Blood pressure,
glucose, and temperature
need to be
monitored, so blood
pressure is kept not
too high. Glucose
also not kept too
high in temperature.
is also lowered. In terms
of secondary prevention,
atrial fibrillation
is treated with
anticoagulation.
Antiplatelet
agents can be used,
such as aspirin,
and statins for
hyperlipidemia.
The different
type of brain
hemorrhages include
epidural hematoma,
subdural hematoma,
intracerebral
hemorrhage, and some
arachnoid hemorrhage.
So case four,
you may remember
Natasha Richardson. On
March 16, 2009, she
fell while skiing on
a beginner hill and
sustained a head injury.
She refused medical
help but complained
of severe headache.
She sustained an
epidural hematoma and
died two days later.
So a fracture of which
part of the skull
is likely to be
associated with a middle
meningeal artery
laceration and why.
So this is the,
it's called the
terion, P-T-E-R-I-O
-N, where several of
the skull bones
come together and
it's also associated
with a weakness.
The epidural hematoma
is often traumatic.
It has a lens shape
appearance and there is
association of middle
meningeal artery rupture
after a skull fracture.
There could be a
lucid interval before
loss of consciousness,
which may be referred
to as talk and die.
After they are hit,
they will speak for a
little while and seem
lucid, and then can
collapse after that.
A subdural hematoma is
generally due to
trauma, including motor
vehicle accidents,
falls, and assaults. It's
associated with a
crescent-shaped extraaxial
lesion. This is due
to rupture of bridging
veins and occurs
between the dura and the
arachnoid membranes.
It's associated with
trivial or minor head
trauma in susceptible
patients who also may
have cerebral atrophy.
A subarachnoid
hemorrhage can be either
aneurysmal versus
non-aneurysmal.
Perimesencephalic
is the most common
cause of a non
-aneurysmal subarachnoid
hemorrhage. It could
also be due to reversible
cerebral vasoconstriction
syndrome,
posterior reversible
encephalopathy syndrome,
infective endocarditis,
******* use, cortical
vein thrombosis or
other coagulopathies
so case 5 which is a
dissection Jane is
a 40 year old
woman who presented
with a new severe
headache on the right
side of her head and
associated neck pain it
began yesterday it's
the worst headache I
can remember she told
me she had a history of
thyroid cancer and
it was treated with
radiation therapy so an
arterial dissection is
associated with a
blood collection and
intramural hematoma formation
in the arterial wall
layers. It can occur
in the carotid artery,
vertebral artery, or
both. It most commonly
involves the extracranial
vessels and may
occur spontaneously or
as a result of trauma,
a common cause of
****** in young adults.
And other causes include
fibromuscular dysplasia,
EDS, which is
Ehlers-Danlos
syndrome, type 4,
which is the vascular
type, or
polycystic kidney.
Environmental
factors could include
trauma such as
whiplash, use of
oral contraceptives,
or migraine.
The signs and Symptoms
of a dissection
could include new onset
headache, especially
in a carotid dissection.
Neck pain can
occur also for a
vertebral dissection.
An ipsilateral Horner
syndrome may occur.
There can be cranial and
cervical neuropathies,
pulsatile tinnitus,
which means that
they hear their
heartbeat in their
ear, and a TIA or a
****** may result.
A Horner syndrome
is associated with
meiosis, which
is a small pupil,
ptosis, which is
the eyelid lagging,
without anhydrosis,
which is sweating,
can result from the
distention of the
third-order sympathetic
fibers that span
the external surface
of an enlarged
and dissected internal
carotid artery.
so case six was it
was november 2012
several days after
hurricane sandy a 49 year
old woman was brought
into the office by
her sister and she
was in distress she
had a severe headache
was having difficulty
making sense and on
physical exam she
was unable to have
a conversation and
described that she felt
like she was dying she
was visibly
uncomfortable but did not
have other focal
neurologic abnormalities.
So this was a venous
infarction and the
questions to consider
what are the most
common presenting
symptoms of a
cerebral venous infarction
and what diagnostic
tests are required
to diagnose it.
So with a venous
thrombosis, the rates
are higher than previously
thought. They're
higher among women
of reproductive age
and consistently three
times higher than
their male counterparts
of the same age.
Associated conditions
with venous infarctions
are prothrombotic
diseases, antiphospholipid
syndrome, cancer,
oral contraceptive
use, and infections
including COVID-19.
Prothrombotic
conditions include
factor V Leiden
mutations,
prothrombin G20210A,
protein S deficiency,
protein C deficiency,
antithrombin
deficiencies, and
antiphospholipid syndrome.
And this is a
quick view of the
venous, the cerebral
venous system.
The clinical syndromes
of a venous thrombosis
is as follows.
They are diverse.
presentation can be
divided into four
syndromes. The first is
a headache, which occurs
in over 90% of patients
associated with
increased intracranial
pressure. There
can be focal neurologic
presentations and
or seizures. There
could be the presence
of subacute
encephalopathy, which is
mostly a mental status
change, and also can
be associated with
cavernous sinus
syndrome with multiple
cranial neuropathies.
Now, making the
diagnosis requires
a high degree
of suspicion.
Cerebral angiogram
is the gold
standard, but non
-invasive imaging
would be better
if possible.
CT and MR venography,
or MRI with contrast,
is most preferred.
A hemorrhagic
conversion is seen
in greater than
one-third of
patients, and maybe an
often parisaginal
in distribution.
So moving forward,
for the first time now
in 2024, there are
guidelines for primary
****** prevention,
meaning to prevent a
****** from coming on
in the first place. And
these are what are
called life's essential
eight, a healthy diet,
physical activity,
healthy weight,
healthy sleep,
avoiding tobacco
products, healthy
levels of blood
lipids, healthy levels
of blood glucose,
and blood pressure
management.
So in summary, the
important things
are to be able to
localize brain lesions
based on the patient's
presentation.
remember that there
are also venous
strokes in addition
to arterial strokes
and be able to
recognize them. Thank
you very much for
your attention.